[Musik]
ich bin seit den frühen 80er Jahren
Polizist
ich wollte mich immer mit Kapital
Verbrechen befassen aber wurde
schließlich Leiter der Abteilung für
Schwerverbrechen in cambricher
[Musik]
Jahre habe ich in mindestens 20 bis 30
Mordfällen ermittelt
first die ersten zwei drei Tage einer
mord-untersuchung sind extrem intensiv
als leitender Ermittler muss man alles
koordinieren
dies war kein Tatort sondern ein
Leichenfundort
hier hat der Täter die Leiche deponiert
um unerkannt davon zu kommen
dabei hat er vermutlich
Überwachungskameras Zeugen und alles was
auf ihn hindeutet vermieten
das heißt die nächsten 72 Stunden läuft
alles auf Hochtouren
der Fall geht dir nicht aus dem Kopf er
beschäftigt dich bis spät nachts und du
bekommst kein Auge zu der vereinnahmt
dich total in Großbritannien gibt es nur
wenige ungelöste Mordfälle da will man
nicht derjenige sein der einen Mord
nicht aufklären kann
[Musik]
ich war vier Jahre lang Ermittler bevor
ich Leiter der Kriminalpolizei wurde
dieser Fall war auch für mich etwas
Neues ich hatte noch nie mitten in der
Nacht mitten im Nirgendwo mit einer
verkohlten Leiche zu tun gehabt
um vier Uhr morgens rief man mich an ich
war der leitende Ermittler auf Abruf
en in der Zentrale war gerade eine
Meldung eingegangen
auf einem Rastplatz in der Nähe von
Hengsten hatte man eine brennende Leiche
gefunden
ich zog mich an und sprang ins Auto
ich wusste dass Beweise verloren gehen
könnten wenn ich nicht schnell genug
dort ankam
der Rastplatz vor Hengsten ist ziemlich
groß es standen vier oder fünf
Sattelschlepper dort deren Fahrer dort
übernachteten
LKW war um etwa 23 morgens aufgewacht
im Rückspiegel sah er ein Feuer hinter
seinem Wagen er war besorgt dass jemand
den LKW in Brand gesteckt hatte
also stand er auf und ging nach hinten
wo er die zwei Koffer entdeckte Kaiser
Notrufzentrale wir brennenden Koffer da
ist eine Leiche drin
das war um 3 Uhr
sobald ich ankam verteilte ich Aufgaben
ich musste schnellstmöglich das ganze
Orchester zusammenstellen das ist ein
Ausdruck den wir gerne verwenden als
leitender Ermittler bist du der Dirigent
du bestimmst wie die Instrumente
eingesetzt werden um einen Fall zu lösen
es bestand die große Gefahr dass die
Feuerwehr beim Löschen mit dem Schlauch
Beweise vernichtet aber es musste so
schnell wie möglich gelöscht werden
damit wir alle noch vorhandenen Spuren
sichern konnten
[Musik]
ich sprach mit dem Leiter der
Feuerwehrmannschaft dann benutzten sie
Trinkbecher um das Feuer mit so wenig
Wasser wie möglich zu löschen und die
Zersetzung der Leiche zu stoppen
auf ein paar Meter
[Musik]
und er kannte deutlich einen
menschlichen Körper
man sah einen verkohlten Schädel und
eine Hand und es raucht nach
Brandbeschleuniger es war grauenhaft
ich sagte Allen sie sollen auf Abstand
gehen
ich fragte mich warum liegt hier eine
brennende Leiche warum an diesem Ort wer
hat die Leiche hier abgelegt
es könnte einer der Lkw-Fahrer gewesen
sein ein Anwohner oder jemand der von
Weit Weg hierher gefahren ist es gab
keine Zeugen außerdem Fahrer der das
Feuer entdeckt hatte
niemand hatte gesehen wie ein Auto
Einfuhr oder jemand das Feuer legte wir
hatten keinerlei Hinweise
ich teilte drei Teams ein um die
Umgebung zu untersuchen
etwa 150 Meter in diese Richtung und 150
Meter hinunter bis zum Kreisverkehr
wir suchten nach reifen Spuren und
sonstigen zurückgelassenen Beweisen zu
dem Zeitpunkt kannten wir den Tatort
noch nicht aber die Mordwaffe konnte
hier entsorgt worden sein in einem der
umliegenden Felder oder Büsche
alle Lkw-Fahrer wurden befragt wir
wollten wissen warum und wie lange sie
auf dem Rastplatz waren und was sie
gesehen hatten außerdem nahmen wir von
allen eine Speichelprobe
das war wichtig falls einer von ihnen
vor unserer Ankunft am leichten Fundort
war und dort Spuren hinterlassen hat wir
mussten sie als Verdächtige ausschließen
können
es war ein seltsamer Ort eine Leiche
abzulegen
ein Rastplatz so nah an der Autobahn
dort standen fünf LKW direkt neben einer
brennenden Leiche
obwohl es mitten in der Nacht war musste
der Täter damit rechnen dass man sie
findet
warum hatte er einen so exponierten
Platz gewählt
hätte er sie auf einem abgelegenen Feld
oder im Wald verbrannt wäre sie
vielleicht erst viel später entdeckt
worden das hieß für mich dass er die
Gegend nicht kannte und in Panik gerät
[Musik]
im Morgengrauen des 19 Juni 2008
versammelt markberg ein Team von
Kriminaltechnikern am Fundort der Leiche
[Musik]
da Sie hier den Elementen ausgesetzt ist
stehen die Forensiker unter Zeitdruck
alle Spuren zu sichern und Antworten zu
finden
auf dem Rastplatz gibt es keine
Überwachungskameras und es geschah in
den frühen Morgenstunden darum gab es
wahrscheinlich keine Zeugen es war also
eine große Herausforderung
die Fachkenntnis des rechtsmediziners
übersteigt meine Fähigkeiten bei weitem
ich wollte wissen welche Informationen
er mir nach einem ersten Blick auf die
Leiche geben kann denn anfangs wusste
ich nicht einmal ob es ein Mann eine
Frau oder ein Kind war
es war ein zierlicher Körper der
Pathologe sagte es könnte sich um ein
vor pubertäres Kind handeln
wir hatten es vielleicht mit einem
Kindsmörder zu tun
wie aus der Untersuchung des
rechtsmediziners hervorging hatte der
Täter die Leiche zweigeteilt und einen
Arm abgetrennt
wir hatten also drei Leichenteile in
zwei Koffern warum war die Leiche
zerstückelt und verbrannt worden zu
diesem Zeitpunkt gingen wir noch davon
aus dass das Opfer möglicherweise ein
kleines Mädchen war
[Musik]
wir gaben einen Zeugenaufruf heraus
ich forderte Überwachungsvideos aus dem
Umkreis an
ich erwartete das absperrungsgebiet rund
um den Fundort
und schickte ein Team los um alle Videos
aus dem Zeitraum zwischen Mitternacht
und 3 Uhr morgens zu sichern
es war offensichtlich dass der Täter in
diesem Zeitraum zum Rastplatz gefahren
war
[Musik]
ich zog ein Spezialteam der
Spurensicherung hinzu das den Boden
manuell abtastete
die Identität des Opfers ist unbekannt
ohne konkreten Ermittlungsansatz hofft
die Polizei darauf forensisches Material
am Leichenfundort zu sichern
es meldeten sich einige Zeugen die das
Feuer gesehen hatten sogar Polizeibeamte
die daran vorbeigefahren waren
alle hielten es nur für ein kleines
Lagerfeuer auf dem Rastplatz natürlich
ahnte keiner dass es eine brennende
Leiche war
keine Information der Zeugen lieferte
uns einen konkreten Anhaltspunkt
würden wir den Fahrer dieses Wagens 100
Meter weiter stoppen und fragen was er
hier gerade gesehen hat wäre die Antwort
wohl nichts
die Leute achten nicht darauf und wenn
ein Auto vor den Koffern stand konnte
man auch nicht sehen
[Musik]
wir brauchten eine Antwort auf zwei
entscheidende Fragen
wie lange war das Opfer schon tot und
wie lange lag die Leiche am Fundort eine
Autopsie kann das nicht zuverlässig
beantworten also musste ich
insektenexperten zu Rate ziehen
[Applaus]
die forensische Entomologie nutzt
Insekten zur Aufklärung von
Kriminalfällen am häufigsten um die
sogenannte leichenliegezeit zu bestimmen
Schmeißfliegen haben einen sehr guten
Geruchssinn sobald eine Leiche zu
verwesen beginnt zieht sie fliegen an
die sich von ihr ernähren das Weibchen
legt Eier auf der Leiche aus denen dann
winzige Maden schlüpfen
indem wir das Alter dieser Insekten
bestimmen können wir herausfinden seit
wann die Person mindestens tot ist
angenommen die Leiche war kurz nach dem
Todeszeitpunkt für fliegen zugänglich
bei heißem Wetter im Sommer würde man
dann nach fünf Tagen Larven vorfinden
solange der Körper durch das Feuer nicht
vollständig eingeäschert wurde fände man
immer noch Spuren von Insekten
[Musik]
nach der entomologischen Untersuchung
wussten wir dass das Opfer seit
mindestens 5 Tagen tot war
der Täter hatte sich also Zeit gelassen
er zerteilte die Leiche
denn packte die Leichenteile in die
Koffer
und verbrannte sie fünf Tage später was
war in diesen fünf Tagen mit ihr
geschehen
ist dieses Zeitfenster eröffnete uns
neue Ansatzpunkte es war die
entscheidende Information die uns
gefehlt hatte wir wussten nicht wo die
Leiche fünf Tage lang war
oder wer das Opfer war aber wir wussten
dass es vor etwa fünf Tagen starb
36 Stunden nach Auffinden der Leiche
wird sie zur weiteren Analyse ins
eddenburgs Hospital gebracht
härtete wie ist diese Person gestorben
und welche Spuren konnten uns die
Überreste liefern um uns zum Täter zu
führen
die Leiche lag in drei Teilen auf dem
Seziertisch
der Pathologe stellte fest dass
vermutlich ein Winkelschleifer verwendet
wurde um sie zu zerstückeln
außerdem ließ sie eine starke Verletzung
im Brustbereich auf
wie ist sie entstanden war das die
Todesursache es gab auch Verletzungen an
den Händen
wir Entnahmen eine DNA-Probe und blicken
Sie mit der nationalen Datenbank ab wir
wollten feststellen ob die Person
polizeilich bekannt war und so
identifiziert werden konnte
[Musik]
aber das führte zu keinem Ergebnis
also mussten wir auf altmodische Art
versuchen einen Fingerabdruck zu
bekommen
eine Hand war zu stark beschädigt an der
anderen gab es nur einen Finger der
potenziell einen Abdruck liefern konnte
sie arbeiteten stundenlang daran die
Rußpartikel zu entfernen und einen
Fingerabdruck zu bekommen der klar genug
für eine Identifikation war
während sich Kriminaltechniker um einen
Fingerabdruck bemühen untersucht eine
forensische Archäologin die Überreste
auf weitere Hinweise
die Leiche war extrem verbrannt
die Haut war starke schmerzt und
stellenweise verloren gegangen
ich hatte Angst dass das Skelett zu
beschädigt ist um Aufschluss zu bieten
mir war schnell klar dass es sich um die
Überreste eines Erwachsenen handelte
nicht um die eines Kindes
hallo zuerst betrachtete ich das Becken
es sah eindeutig weiblich aus
dann untersuchte ich den Schädel auf
geschlechtsspezifische Merkmale
davon war weiblich
ich konnte also ziemlich zuversichtlich
sagen dass dies eine Frau war
der nächste Schritt war die
Altersbestimmung
bei Erwachsenen betrachten wir dabei die
Entwicklung und Abnutzung verschiedener
Knochen und Gelenke
die wichtigsten Anhaltspunkte liefert
das Schambein
ich stellte fest dass sie in dieser
Kategorie hier lag 19 bis 40 Jahre und
zwar in der ersten Hälfte das heißt sie
war 19 bis 25 Jahre alt
die Vermessung der Knochen ergab dass
sie etwa 1,52 m groß und von sehr
zierlichem Körperbau war
dann musste ich ihre ethnische
Zugehörigkeit bestimmen
dazu betrachtet man wiederum den Schädel
lenken die Länge von vorne nach hinten
seine Krümmung und die Form der
Wangenknochen
ich stellte fest dass der Schädel
kaukasischen Ursprungs war das heißt zu
einer Volksgruppe gehört die Europa
Nordafrika sowie West- und Südasien
abdeckt
aber erwies spezielle Merkmale auf die
nicht typisch europäisch waren
ich bin zufällig auch Ägyptologin und
habe im Laufe meiner Karriere schon mit
tausenden von altägyptischen Schädeln
gearbeitet
und dieser Schädel ähnelte Ihnen sehr
[Musik]
empfahl ich die Ermittlungen auf eine
Frau nordostafrikanischer Abstammung zu
konzentrieren
das Profil des Opfers ist eingegrenzt
nun ist es Aufgabe des rechtsmediziners
die Todesursache zu ermitteln
das gab eine Stichwunde durch die rechte
Brust in die Lunge
die Hände Wissen Schnittwunden auf die
mit Abwehrverletzungen übereinstimmten
das Opfer hatte also versucht sich mit
den Händen zu schützen während der Täter
auf es einstach
[Musik]
all diese Verletzungen aus nächster Nähe
und die Tatsache dass die Leiche erst
fünf Tage nach dem Mord auf dem
Rastplatz deponiert wurde Sprachen dafür
dass das Opfer den Täter gekannt hatte
[Musik]
der Druck durch die Medien steigt rasant
wenn man bei den Ermittlungen nicht
schnell vorankommt
in den ersten 72 Stunden hat man noch
ein wenig Spielraum aber wenn man dann
keinen nennenswerten Fortschritt macht
wenden Sie sich schnell gegen einen und
Fragen sind sie diesem Fall gewachsen
bei weiblichen Opfern ist der Täter in
der Regel männlich aber ich habe alle
Möglichkeiten in Betracht gezogen meine
Vermutung war dass das Opfer seinen
Mörder kannte
[Musik]
ein Suchteam durchkämmte weiter den
äußeren Ring des leichenfundorts die
Straßen waren noch gesperrt das war etwa
36 Stunden nach Eingang der Meldung
ich hatte zwischendurch vielleicht zwei
drei Stunden Schlaf aber noch keine
nützliche Spur
bei einer Ermittlung konzentrieren wir
uns auf drei Dinge
Opfer Täter und Tatort die zentralen
Elemente jedes Kriminalfalls kennt man
alle drei kann man den Fall aufklären
ist zu diesem Zeitpunkt wussten wir
nichts über den Tatort
das Opfer
oder den Mörder
nachdem die Expertin das Opfer als
zierliche Frau Anfang 20 mit vermutlich
nordafrikanischer Abstammung
identifiziert hat gibt Mark Burge diese
Details sofort an seine Ermittlerteam
weiter
kurz darauf erhielt ich einen Anruf
die Kriminaltechniker hatten nach
stundenlanger Arbeit einen teilabdruck
des Fingers gewonnen und mit der
nationalen Datenbank abgeglichen
und wir hatten einen Treffer wir wussten
wer das Opfer war
wer positiv mehr ihr Name war Ramona
amedin
sie stammte aus Äthiopien war knapp ein
Meter fünfzig groß und sehr zierlich
alle Angaben der forensischen
Archäologin stimmten perfekt überein
e Ramona war im Jahr zuvor nach einem
häuslichen Zwischenfall mit ihrem
Partner verhaftet worden
wir könnten also nicht nur ihre
Identität sondern wussten auch dass sie
eine gewalttätige Beziehung geführt
hatte sie war verhaftet worden also
hatte es eindeutig eine
gegenbeschuldigung gegeben
wie wir feststellten war sie vor kurzem
als vermisst gemeldet worden
von ihrem Partner Jamal bucket
[Musik]
wir forchten nach wo sie gewohnt und
gearbeitet hatte und inwiefern sie
anderweitig aufgefallen war
wir wollten alles über sie herausfinden
[Musik]
natürlich auch über ihn wer war er wie
kam es zu der Vermisstenmeldung
[Musik]
wir kontaktierten unsere Kollegen in
London wobei der eine Wohnung hatten
[Musik]
am 14 Juni hatte er sie als vermisst
gemeldet
angeblich hatte er sie zuletzt gesehen
als sie am 6 juni nach Bristol fuhr
seitdem sei sie verschwunden
wussten wir nur wenig er stammte aus
Uganda war nach London gezogen und hatte
dort verschiedene Arbeitsstellen bevor
er einen Waschsalon in full Hammer
übernahm
er war seit einigen Jahren mit Ramona
armedin liiert sie führten eine ziemlich
gewalttätige Beziehung
viel mehr war uns über ihn nicht bekannt
Paket ging auf ein Polizeirevier und
machte eine Vermisstenmeldung das an
sich ist schon ungewöhnlich es kommt
nicht oft vor dass ein Mann eine
erwachsene Frau als vermisst meldet
etwas
nahm sagte dass er dabei sehr sachlich
war als wüsste er schon wie die Sache
ausgeht
ein Polizist ging in die Wohnung um ein
paar Details zu klären er sah auf den
ersten Blick nichts ungewöhnliches
die Polizei befragte zwei Freundinnen
von Ramona sie waren nach deren
Verschwinden in der Wohnung gewesen
ist
Verhalten machte ihnen Angst
habe sie nicht gesehen bei 10 hat
persönliche Gegenstände von Ramona in
der Wohnung darunter ihren Pass sie
nahmen ihn mit
die Wohnung war dunkel er behauptete das
Licht ginge nicht weil es einen
Stromausfall gegeben hätte
offenbar gab es dort Beweise die sie bei
Licht gesehen hätten
wir wussten dass sie seit fünf Tagen tot
war aber danach wurden ihr Handy und
ihre Bankkarte benutzt um es so aussehen
zu lassen als sei sie noch am Leben
wir vermuteten dass sie in London
ermordet worden war wahrscheinlich in
der gemeinsamen Wohnung
ich kontaktierte die Kollegen in London
die seine Spur zurückverfolgten
was er für ein Auto fuhr konnten wir die
Datenbank durchsuchen
und Bingo
auf einem Überwachungsvideo via um 2 Uhr
nachts in eine Tankstelle an der
m-eleven eingefahren war nicht weit
entfernt vom Fundort der Leiche
nur eineinhalb Stunden vor der Meldung
des LKW-Fahrers
wir brennenden Koffer das eine Leiche
drin
für die Ermittler gibt es nur eine
Erklärung dafür warum Jamal Beckett um 2
Uhr morgens an dieser Tankstelle gewesen
war
hinzu kommt die Verdächtige
Vermisstenmeldung und die Geschichte
häuslicher Gewalt zwischen dem Paar die
Polizei beschließt ihn zu verhaften
ich verhafte sie wegen Mordverdacht
und mehr stellte sich stur und gab den
Mord nicht zu
groß wir fragten ihn ob er nach Ramonas
verschwinden ihre Bankkarte oder Ihr
Handy benutzt hatte er bestritt es er
bestritt jegliche Beteiligung an dem
Mord
[Musik]
als wir ihn fragten warum er am 18 juni
an der Tankstelle war behauptete er er
wollte dort jemanden wegen eines
Bewerbungsgesprächs treffen
2 Uhr nachts
meine Erfindung
bis jetzt wie es alles darauf hin dass
Ramona in der Wohnung ermordet worden
war
[Musik]
das war nun unser Tatort
des Mordes bot sich hier ein Bild des
Schreckens
verletzte sie schwer an den Händen
und nachdem sie tot war
hat er sie zerstückelt
dazu benutzte er vermutlich einen
Winkelschleifer es war ein Gemetzel
[Musik]
es muss alles voll Blut gewesen sein wir
hatten erwartet dass wir in der Wohnung
eine Unmenge an Beweisen sichern können
[Applaus]
aber wir fanden
so gut wie nichts
[Musik]
bei der Untersuchung des Tatorts wurde
klar dass er eine gründliche Reinigung
durchgeführt hatte
wir fanden putzmittelrückstände und
winzige Spuren von Ramonas Blut im
Badezimmer
das in eine Plastiktüte eingewickelt war
aber nicht die enorme Menge an
Blutspritzern die wir erwartet hatten
ins Claire jamalbakit hatte
offensichtlich stundenlang geputzt
[Musik]
um jegliche Spuren seiner Tat zu
beseitigen
bei der Hausdurchsuchung werden Ramonas
Handtasche Handy und andere persönliche
Gegenstände entdeckt nach Ansicht der
Ermittler hätte sie diese bei einem
freiwilligen Verlassen der Wohnung
mitgenommen
für mich hieß es dass ihre Ermordung im
Affekt geschah vermutlich infolge eines
Streits mit ihrem Partner
es ist aus
aus und tötete sie
und danach versuchte er seine Spuren zu
verwischen um nicht überführt zu werden
hier hat der Ramona ermordet und ihre
Leiche zerteilt
[Musik]
wie man sieht ist es hier sehr ruhig
schon kurz nach der Abend der Mauer
in fast menschenleerer Platz im
Hinterhof einer belebten Londoner Straße
unterwegs keiner sieht aus dem Fenster
[Musik]
in diesen Häusern wohnen sicher tausend
Leute
unvorstellbar das hinter einer dieser
Türen jemand unbemerkt brutal ermordet
und zerstückelt wurde
in diesem Haus ist es passiert
[Musik]
der Besuch von Ramonas Freundinnen muss
ihn aufgeschreckt haben eine sagte dass
es in der Wohnung stand sie vermutlich
war das der Verwesungsgeruch von Ramonas
Leiche
Paket musste sich etwas einfallen lassen
von ihren Freundinnen erwischt worden
jetzt musste er schnell handeln
das Geräusch einer elektrischen Säge
mitten in der Nacht wäre einem Nachbarn
aufgefallen
er hat die Leiche also wohl eher
tagsüber zerstückelt aber sie dann erst
spät nachts aus dem Haus geschafft
wenn er muss das Haus zwischen ein und
zwei Uhr nachts verlassen haben denn
kurz darauf wurde er an der Tankstelle
gesehen
er ging also zwischen ein und zwei Uhr
nachts hier mit den Koffern über den Hof
und verstaute sie im Auto
vom Haus bis zum Parkplatz sind es
12 Schritte
und wahrscheinlich hat das niemand
gesehen hier ist es Menschen leer keiner
sieht aus dem Fenster er dachte sich
wohl dass er damit davon kommt
[Musik]
wir verlassen gerade die Eleven das wäre
bakis Route gewesen
es herrschte zu dem Zeitpunkt kaum
Verkehr
er fuhr auf dieser Spur an die Zapfsäule
am 18 juni früh morgens das Benzin
besorgt
ein Liter hat wohl gereicht
er versuchte um jeden Preis einer
Gefangennahme zu entgehen er wollte die
Leiche entsorgen und dabei keinerlei
forensischen Spuren hinterlassen
er putzte die Wohnung
aber er hat zwei Dinge nicht bedacht die
automatische Nummernschild Erkennung
und die Überwachungskameras an der
Tankstelle
bei der Untersuchung von Straftaten sind
Sie ein Geschenk des Himmels denn immer
wieder werden Täter dank der Zeitangaben
auf Überwachungsvideos überführt
nach dem Stopp an der Tankstelle fuhr er
weiter
zurück auf die m-eleven Richtung Norden
weit weg von der Stadt da finde ich
einen sicheren Ort da werde ich sie los
er wollte sich die Leiche
schnellstmöglich vom Hals schaffen
wir sind jetzt etwa zwölf Kilometer vom
Leichenfundort entfernt der ganz nah an
der Autobahn lag er ist bei der
erstbesten Ausfahrt rausgefahren
[Applaus]
ich verstehe bis heute nicht warum er
nicht ins Feld hinunter ging und die
Koffer da in Brand steckte
von der Straße aus hätte man sie nicht
gesehen er fuhr bei der ersten Ausfahrt
raus um die Leiche abzuladen
und zu verbrennen
[Musik]
als er zurück auf die Autobahn fuhr
glaubte er sicher er hätte es geschafft
denn bis zum Morgen wäre die Leiche
komplett verbrannt und mit ihr jegliche
Beweise
ich habe nichts damit zu tun okay
wir hatten in seiner Wohnung ein in
Plastik eingewickeltes Messer gefunden
Blutspuren des Opfers
persönliche Gegenstände des Opfers
wurde eineinhalb Stunden vor Entdeckung
der Leiche ganz in der Nähe von der
Kamera erfasst
[Musik]
und trotz dieser erdrückenden Beweislage
bestritt er alles
[Musik]
der Anklage zufolge war ihre Beziehung
von Eifersucht und Machtspielchen
geprägt er hatte sie schon in der
Vergangenheit misshandelt
laut Freunden hatte er gedroht sich
umzubringen wenn sie ihn je verlässt
und sie beschuldigt Affären zu haben
wir müssen reden
er verlor die Nerven
verlor die Beherrschung
und in seiner Garage tötete er sie
dann hackte er den Plan aus sie als
vermisst zu melden und ihre Leiche zu
entsorgen
die Geschworenen brauchten nur
eineinhalb Stunden in des Mordes für
schuldig zu befinden
[Musik]
der Urteilsverkündung zeigte er
keinerlei Emotionen er wurde zu
lebenslanger Haft verurteilt
[Applaus]
das Lösen dieses Falls war sehr
befriedigend denn anfangs war uns
einfach alles ein Rätsel
doch es war so ein sinnloser Tod
ramona ameden ist der rasenden
Eifersucht ihres Freundes zum Opfer
gefallen
[Musik]